Dylan is with us in Indianapolis hi
Dylan how are you I'm doing great Dave
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up um well a quick little
background for you I'm 23 and I live
with my fiancee here in Indy we are in
baby step 2 and looking to pay off about
$10,000 worth of debt by the end of the
year so we've been attacking it hard and
the question is actually referring to my
fiancee has a sister who is 24 she lives
right now with her parents and she's
just been having a lot of struggles
financially she's upside down on a car
payment I know and just really
struggling career-wise as well
she's expressed a desire to come and
live with us for a while in Indy and get
back up on her feet and I want to know
what's a smart way to try and help her
as I do have a desire to help her but I
don't want it to cause any kind of
stress between myself and you know my
future wife because I don't want it
there ever to be a situation where she's
you know stuck between myself and her
sister well too late the he so when's
the wedding date we're looking for
sometime around Christmas next year okay
why are you waiting into a Christmas
next year we would like for her to
finish college before we get married
she's about to graduate for on PA school
why I don't know we just felt like it
was a good decision to try and wait a
little bit and make sure that we're you
know waiter and job right so I don't
know what the difference is you're right
okay just something to think about
because it kind of affects the other
question I'm not just being a smart out
like okay because this is your
sister-in-law or it's your girlfriend's
sister there's a difference right okay
girlfriends sister I can step on them a
lot easier and I can my sister-in-law
you know and so you got to walk that
through so here's the thing it takes
strength to be gentle you guys are not
standing on a really strong
relational strength right now you're not
married and you're not standing on
really strong financial strength and for
you all to be gentle with this other
girl who's not got her act together who
happens to be a sister it's gonna be
hard it's gonna be hard because you
don't have a lot of margin you know
versus like Sharon and I've been married
35 years we got a bazillion dollars okay
so we could handle this kid without any
trouble you see what I'm saying you see
the difference and so you guys every
little thing is going to be sandpaper
every little thing is going to be
fingernails on a chalkboard um and so I
if you were married for three days or
three weeks and you called NASA same
question I would have to say I think
it's a really good thing for you guys to
help her add a little bit more of a
distance than down the hallway mm-hmm I
wouldn't move her in with you I'd let
you I would put your relationship ahead
of her need I want to help her along
with you but there's there's really a
lot I'm just being an old guy now not a
financial guy okay there's just a lot of
downside to this relationally and
because you know she comes in there you
can't there's no there's nothing you if
your fiance decides she's gonna be an
enabler and give her sister money you
you start stepping in and saying that's
a bad idea
you're gonna be the bad guy and really
and you know or you get to participate
in the enabling and both of these things
are stupid and so nobody's going to tell
this girl no because everybody's stand
off and from each other it's
triangulated and I Eve I wouldn't move
her in if she wants to come to town will
feed her occasionally she can come by
with love her and she needs to get a
roommate have a job and come to town and
get her act together and be like a
stand-up adult if she comes she could
come for three weeks and stay while
she's looking for her first place but at
the end of three weeks pre-arranged
three weeks an exact date that we've
initialed on the email that says we will
be out by this date
and so otherwise you look up three years
later and that three weeks is still
going
so yeah just put a date on it and yeah
it's just dangerous really really
dangerous for you guys and hey thanks
for the call this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]